if you're in the world of instant
gratification forget about
entrepreneurship cuz what comes quick
leaves quicker entrepreneurship and
hustling is about a slow but a for show
that's what you want don't let these
boys fool you and make you think that
something just happens that quick you
got to understand there's no magic to
this there's no secret sauce no secret
formula hard work pays off you put in
the time and time will pay you back but
if you think one way or another you're
just going to microwave some kind of
opportunity SL
entrepreneurship or or business and
startup and you think it's going to pay
you back like that it's going to pay you
exactly what you did